hello everyone it's October 31st 2016
and tomorrow on November 1st I
officially start my patreon drawing
project for those who don't know I'm
starting a project to draw different
carvings from the history of Christian
art to explore the language of carved
icons in the past and for everyone who
gives $25.00 to this patreon project a
month I will be sending you a drawing at
the end of the year and so I would like
to thank my first 14 patrons who are
just amazing I'm really excited that
you're there and I hope that you'll be
able to criticize my work and to
participate in the process to give me
ideas and so I'm very excited to get
this started as you can see it's a it's
a nice cool autumn day today behind me
this is my workshop where I carve and
well be making those drawings I just
finished the first drawing I had started
a drawing of Saint Mama's from Georgia
and reppu say that I love very much and
for the next drawing I'm going to do I'm
actually going to do what make one of my
favorite images which is 11th century
carved ivory of Christ blessing the the
Emperor Roman nose and you'd okiya and
so please stay tuned share this project
anybody you think would be interested
and I hope